[Music]
a pittsburgh synagogue devastated by a
mass shooting
is looking to rebuild itself for a
brighter future
you may remember that a hate-filled
gunman stormed into the tree of life
synagogue
during saturday morning services almost
three years ago
11 people were killed and six others
hurt
now one of the world's best known
architects aims to transform the site of
tragedy
into a place that inspires hope our jim
axelrod spoke with the architect
and the congregation's rabbi jim good
morning good morning and it was a deep
and meaningful conversation anthony the
architect the rabbi
and every member of the tree of life
congregation are being guided by three
words as they try to plan a way forward
for the scene of this unspeakable horror
remember rebuild and renew
in pittsburgh the architect daniel
liebuskind is beginning his latest
project like so much of his other work
this one too
is rooted in devastation he walked
through a site
of murder of a mass murder of the
greatest attack on
on jews in this country liebeskind who
navigated complex emotional terrain
designing the ground zero site
and the jewish museum in berlin will now
lead the rebuild of the tree of life
campus
closed since the shooting on october 27
2018
when a hate-filled gunman murdered 11
and
injured six during shabbat services it's
not just a walk-through
disaster you walk through the memory
of what happened and you think of the
significance what will this mean
what does it tell us liebeskind the son
of holocaust survivors recently made his
first trip to pittsburgh to meet with
rabbi jeffrey meyers and members of the
congregation
the drawings are done here my father did
the job
examine artifacts of the day and begin
to consider
a way forward how do you decide whether
you knock it all down because
it's just too full of horror you have to
walk through
and imagine we're traces of importance
on the side
what is not just salvageable but
inspires us
still and how do we document the past
as it falls unfolds to a brighter future
it's a delicate balancing act
marking trauma while wrestling hope
from the pain one of the if not the
governing principles
will be making sure everyone is reminded
that there is more light than darkness
that's absolutely true
light has to be than the message of the
place because
we do live in darkness a lot of the time
and we saw the darkness and the evil
of the events that befell on this
congregation
but i think a building has to do
something else has to
has to give you a sense of inspiration a
breath of life
and there's an excitement of well
we can't wait to see what this will
become
rabbi myers took us for a walk past the
site they have optimism for a bright
future
pointing to artwork sent from around the
world including students at marjory
stoneman douglas high school that hope
can come out of the horror of
of what happened at that school to me
that's just incredible
it's provided inspiration about a
direction for the project
i've come to learn that through two and
a half years
through letters emails cards phone calls
from people around the world complete
strangers there's this vast silent
majority out there in the world
who are good decent people yeah the time
has come
that the silent majority become a vocal
majority to say to the rest of the world
this is unacceptable you cannot deny
what happened on that site
you have to be able to integrate in a
meaningful way while it's early in the
process
daniel liebuskin rabbi myers and the
tree of life community
are beginning to frame a mission
building a beachhead in the battle
between tolerance and hate what stories
will you be telling with the design and
construction
of the site at the tree of life
the tree of life will not be meister it
will be story of the people
who are there on that day it'll be the
story of
beauty of fatality of death but also of
rebirth
of renewal of inspiration
as daniel liebeska knows all too well
from the complex
challenges his other projects have
presented to him it takes time
to figure out the right balance between
remembering rebuilding and renewing
we're told the design process is
expected to be completed and ground
should be broken
by early next year yeah i love the
message light has to be the message of
the place
so that was to me the most moving part
of the whole interview when rabbi myers
you could hear his voice
in the last bite of the uh the piece
there that
that that there is a silent majority of
good decent people that need to become a
vocal majority
this campus the tree of life campus
needs to be the place
where that idea can take longer what
they say at the tree of life itself
already is
more light equals more life yeah well if
daniel liebskin can can
design a jewish museum in berlin you
know he can his work is always about
resilience yeah
ground zero as well i just think about
the strength he must have to constantly
be working in the space of all this
tragedy and turning it into something
hopeful
absolutely thank you very much jim